The booming steps echoed through the museum
corridors.
Pharaohs, emperors, and Mongolian war leaders
all stood stock still as the terrified security
guard ran between them.
Roger Pascal swung his flashlight this way
and that.
The light glinted on the polished steel of
ancient weaponry: muskets, scimitars, and
cannons.
Exhibit after exhibit flashed past him as
he ran through the dark museum.
There was no way it was real, no possible
way.
He was having a bad dream, that's all it was.
A bad dream.
The shaking ground under his feet and the
marching rhythm of the impossibly heavy footsteps
behind him told him that it was real, alright.
It had just been a normal shift like any other,
just a regular night at the museum.
Roger had been sipping his coffee and listening
to the radio, when all of a sudden, he felt
his chair start rumbling beneath him.
He put his coffee down on the table and watched
as it recoiled as the footsteps grew louder
and closer.
He’d got up to investigate and couldn’t
believe what he’d walked in on.
Skidding around the corner, he tumbled into
a medieval suit of armor and sent it crashing
across the floor.
Chainmail helmet, gauntlets, all of it rattled
and crashed to the marble floor, echoing all
through the museum.
Then there was a sudden deathly silence as
the footsteps stopped.
Roger didn’t breathe.
Then they started again, heading straight
towards him.
It was all Roger could do to lie on his back
in front of a giant taxidermy eagle and point
his flashlight at the doorway as the monstrous
figure of the stone soldier walked around
the corner, musket in hand.
*
Woodstock, Vermont, 1995.
It was a normal day just like any other.
The birds were singing in the trees, and there
was a gentle breeze blowing through.
Nothing at all out of the ordinary, except,
of course, the statue that opened its eyes.
The Civil War memorial had been a staple of
Woodstock for well over 100 years, a plinth
sitting in the middle of a park with a young
soldier on top of it, holding a musket peacefully
by his side.
The statue had watched over the town generation
after generation.
Except now its watching had become a little
more active.
It took several hours for anyone to notice.
Dog walkers went past listening to their Walkmans,
a banker sat on a bench opposite, deep in
conversation on a giant brick phone.
It was only when a young child running after
her football looked up at the statue and saw
it looking back at her that things changed.
The girl's parents didn't listen to her, of
course; parents rarely do.
But word quickly went around the girl's school.
Most of the time, the statue was totally still,
no movement in the eyes at all.
But on occasion, when a group of kids gathered
around it and talked to it enough, the statue
seemed to look down at them as if it was listening.
But that was it.
No grown-ups were particularly interested
in what the children were saying, and even
a lot of the children who saw it went home,
concluding that they must have been imagining
things.
So six months went by without anyone really
paying the statue much attention.
That was, until it fired its gun.
In a quiet rural town, everyone hears a gunshot,
but for a long time, no one could work out
where it had come from.
Police gathered around the park, searching
all around where the weapon had been heard.
The only clue they could find was a small
hole in the wall of a shop across the street.
A couple of officers joked that the shot must
have come from the statue itself.
Everyone laughed it off except for a couple
of the school kids who were playing nearby.
Less than two weeks later, another shot rang
out in the middle of the night, and a group
of confused police officers rushed to the
park to investigate what had happened.
The only thing they found was a dead bird
lying on the sidewalk, shot to death.
Again, the jokes went around the department
that it must have been the statue who did
it, except this time, the officers were all
laughing a little less enthusiastically.
Without much crime going on in Woodstock,
Vermont, the department decided to take the
shooting quite seriously, going so far as
to perform an autopsy on the dead pigeon.
But when they cut the animal open and looked
at the wound inside its chest, they were filled
with even more confusion than they were before.
It wasn't a conventional bullet lodged into
the bird's rib cage at all.
It was perfectly round and made of what appeared
to be stone.
But the next shot that rang out from the Memorial
Park was unmistakable.
It was a weekend in the middle of the summer
vacation, so the park was full of families
all sitting around having picnics, BBQs, and
staring up at the sky, watching the birds
circle lazily overhead.
Bang!
One of the pigeons exploded in a burst of
feathers and plummeted out of the sky, landing
on the sidewalk in front of the whole town.
In shock, all of the town's folk turned around
to see the stone statue down on one knee with
his musket on his shoulder.
The statue looked down at all of them, surprised
at the attention, then quickly got back to
its feet and resumed its normal stance.
Reports flooded all of the local papers and
news stations.
The event was blamed on mass hysteria, a kind
of group hallucination where everyone was
somehow sharing the same story.
But the number of people coming forward with
the exact same account was irrefutable evidence.
That's where the Foundation had to step in.
In January 1996, containment procedures began,
and the statue was given the designation SCP-011.
Of course, a large contingent of agents suddenly
appearing in a small town would raise a lot
of suspicion, so the Foundation had to move
very cautiously.
One agent at a time, the Foundation established
itself in Woodstock and began to study the
statue day in, and day out, by sitting on
park benches, even looking through cutout
holes in newspapers, and wearing fake outfits
so as not to arouse suspicion.
Steadily over time, the statue appeared to
gain either a heightened mobility or just
a renewed sense of confidence.
While much of the time it did remain standing
immobile, it would begin to occasionally stretch
when it thought no one was looking and glance
this way and that in apparent annoyance with
the birds circling over its head.
The shootings steadily grew more regular.
Foundation agents observed several birds being
picked out of the sky by the musket fire of
SCP-011 over the following weeks.
A clear pattern started to emerge: the statue
would only fire at birds that seemed to be
flying above it or getting too curious about
it.
In fact, the more fecal matter built up on
the statue, the more aggressive it would be.
Both its body language and mood seemed to
sour the dirtier it got.
While there were initial concerns about the
SCP potentially turning its rifle towards
the local townspeople, these worries were
largely dismissed as SCP-011 gradually started
to build up a rapport with those around it.
Before long, the caretakers of the park were
having exchanges with the SCP.
These exchanges started with the caretakers
speaking directly to the SCP and it nodding
or subtly acknowledging the things they said,
but over time, the interactions grew more
and more personable.
In the year 2000, SCP-011 spoke for the first
time.
It had just fired its rifle, picking off a
pigeon from over 200 feet away, when a caretaker
mildly exclaimed, "Nice shot."
The statue smiled, dipped his hat to the caretaker,
and said, "Thank you," in a gravelly voice.
This marked a significant change in The Foundation's
approach to the containment of SCP-011.
Up until this point, the SCP was considered
a broadly harmless member of the local town
community.
However, its ability to speak raised concerns
as to this SCP's development.
Four years ago, it had been an immobile statue
with nothing out of the ordinary to raise
any suspicions among those around it.
Where would its cognitive development end?
Now it had gained the ability to talk, groundskeepers
and agents posing as groundskeepers struck
up conversations with SCP-011 as often as
possible.
At first, these exchanges were brief, but
over time, the SCP became steadily more vocal
until soon it was engaged in intellectual
debates and sharing its views on the world
with anyone who would listen.
It was becoming clear that new containment
measures were needed.
In fact, SCP-011 soon lost interest in shooting
birds.
Or rather, the SCP was persuaded to stop shooting
While the prospect of having animals defecate
on it still appeared to anger the statue,
The Foundation was able to explain, through
ideological grounds, why shooting birds was
a disproportionate response relative to the
minor harm they were doing to it.
Keen to engage in philosophical and ethical
discussions, the statue was very open to hearing
The Foundation's viewpoint on the issue, and
having sufficiently considered all sides of
the debate, decided that it would, in fact,
be better for the well-being of all involved
if it stopped shooting the birds from the
sky.
In return, the caretakers and Foundation agents
promised to do their best to clean it regularly
and keep the animals at bay.
But with word of this bizarre tourist attraction
steadily gathering momentum as the age of
email began to take off, The Foundation decided
that it would be best to relocate SCP-011
entirely.
However, agents who had been living in Woodstock
for the prior four years were hesitant to
relocate the entity to a test chamber or storage
facility.
The benefits that it had brought to the local
community far outweighed the risks and threats
that it posed.
The statue had become a local celebrity, smiling
and waving at children who went past, and
even offering brief history lessons to any
confused tourists who found themselves wandering
through the park.
Most just assumed it was a person in gray
paint.
It was Agent Khan who came up with the idea
of relocating SCP-011 to a museum.
Being kept indoors away from the dangers of
any fecal bombing runs was the main priority.
Khan argued that within a museum, the statue
would blend in seamlessly with the exhibits
around it.
Furthermore, if anyone did see the statue
move or talk, they would assume that it was
an interactive exhibit and treated it as such.
Having shown a real love for academia, history,
and debate, Khan believed that SCP-011 would
benefit greatly from being in such a setting,
both learning and eventually even teaching
about the history of the American Civil War.
However, when all of these arguments were
put forward to the statue itself, it was hesitant.
Having spent the entirety of its cognitive
existence standing on the same plinth, shooting
at the same pigeons, the idea of relocating
to somewhere new and unknown was very intimidating.
Even with the soldier's mindset, SCP-011 was
still feeling incredibly nervous about the
idea of moving house.
Agent Khan and SCP-011 found themselves locked
in a stalemate.
Try as she might, convincing the SCP to leave
its current home was like talking to a brick
wall, or rather, a stone wall.
The pair of them ended up dropping the conversation
for a couple of years, focusing instead on
psychiatric evaluations and history lessons
for the SCP.
In 2002, the Foundation officially declared
that SCP-011 had achieved sentience with a
great enough level of self-awareness to pass
as a normal human being, aside from the fact
that it was composed entirely of stone.
For two years, Agent Khan talked to SCP-011
every day on the park bench.
The slats of the bench had to be replaced
several times as the weight of the statue
broke through them, snapping them clean in
half on several occasions.
During this period, the pair of them built
up a rapport rarely seen between humans and
SCPs.
So much so that in 2004, Agent Khan managed
to convince SCP-011 to move to a local museum
on one condition: she would go as well.
The Foundation agreed to the terms, deciding
that Khan could take on the role of being
a researcher in the museum.
That way, she could keep an eye on SCP-011
and report any activities while the Foundation
officially relinquished control over the SCP.
What happened next was perhaps rather predictable,
or at least it would be predictable to anyone
who had worked with Agent Khan and SCP-011
during that time in Vermont.
As the pair of them moved into their new lives
at the museum, romantic feelings blossomed
between them.
Seeing as SCP-011 is officially outside of
the SCP Foundation's jurisdiction, there has
been no official inquiry into the nature - and
practicalities - of the relationship between
the women and the statue.
But from the reports that make their way to
the Foundation every three months, it is clear
that both are very much enjoying the privacy
of their new arrangement.
*
Roger Pascal closed his eyes, imagining the
barrel raising higher and higher until it
was pointed squarely at his face.
He had been told by his bosses not to ask
questions about the origins of the statue
that had suddenly appeared in the Civil War
section.
Even when he saw the statue’s eyes moving,
he’d kept his mouth shut.
That was until he was doing his security rounds
that night and heard those booming footsteps
leading him behind one of the displays.
He had rushed over in a panic.
Peering around the corner, he had been shocked
to see Miss Khan, one of the researchers here,
and the Civil War statue engaged in a passionate
kiss.
He had turned and bolted as fast as he could
until he ended up here, terrified on the floor
as he imagined the musket being leveled at
him.
But then a second pair of footsteps joined
the group, and a woman's laugh filled the
room.
Opening his eyes, the security guard saw the
pair of them, the statue and the researcher,
standing in the doorway, laughing about the
whole situation.
The musket was slung over the man's shoulder
as he offered a cold, stony hand down to the
security guard to help him up.
Ironically there was something about the statue’s
smile that softened Roger’s stoney heart
as he was hauled to his feet.
‘I have… so many questions.’
Now check out “SCP-173 Origin Story - How
173 Got to Site-19” and “SCP-1913 Deadly
Monster Squad - The Furies!”